als bull auf scholz' endlich nach kiew
kommt als er selbst die schrecken von
russlands krieg sieht passiert
gleichzeitig dies russland angriffe auf
die ukrainisch zivilbevölkerung gehen
unvermindert weiter und ein putin
vertraute fragt ob die ukraine bald noch
auf der weltkarte existieren der der
stolz der westen genug um der ukraine zu
helfen
scholz ist für den eu kandidatenstatus
beim neuen waffenlieferungen aber bleibt
der waage
unterstützt die ukraine auch mit der
lieferung von waffen- und wir werden das
weiterhin tun solange die ukraine unsere
unterstützung
versprochen hat deutschland unter
anderem panzerhaubitzen raketenwerfer
flugabwehr panzer versprochen aber noch
nicht geliefert die ukraine aber
bräuchte eigentlich noch viel mehr sie
wird ungeduldig und ebenso deutschlands
verbündete
es herrscht immer noch ungewissheit über
das was versprochen worden ist was wird
kommen wo ist es das könnte sehr schnell
geklärt werden wenn der bundeskanzler
und die verteidigungsministerin
öffentlich sagen würden darum wurden wir
gebeten das haben wir versprochen das
haben wir geliefert
es fehlt bei scholz an klaren worten was
deutschland leisten wird es fehlt nicht
an wuchtigen worten
niemand liefert den ähnlich großem
umfang wie deutschland das tut es gibt
ein paar wenige die auch sehr viele
touren wie zum beispiel die vereinigten
staaten von amerika stimmt das so das
kieler weltwirtschaftsinstitut hat am
freitag neue zahlen veröffentlicht
danach liefern nicht nur die usa mehr
sondern auch großbritannien und polen
und nochmal wuchtige worte diesmal ein
versprechen der verteidigungsministerin
also wir haben sehr schnell geliefert
aus den beständen der bundeswehr heraus
geht darum dass es jetzt schnell geht
mit der unterstützung für die ukraine
ist notwendig um jetzt schnell die
ukraine zu unterstützen manchmal ging es
tatsächlich schnell aber insgesamt es
bei kaum einem land die diskrepanz so
groß wie bei deutschland zwischen dem
was versprochen also dem oberen beiden
und dem was geliefert wurde
ich habe den eindruck dass seite
entscheidungen im deutschen bundestag wo
geklärt worden ist was die strategie ist
dass wir liefern dass wir auch schwere
waffen liefern wir einfach ganze reihe
von bürokratischen hemmnissen haben dass
das verteidigungsministerium schneller
werden muss und es muss dringend
überwunden werden dabei könnte
eigentlich viel mehr geliefert werden
und auch viel schneller schon vor wochen
haben wir die alten leopard 1 panzer
berichtet in einem zelt in flensburg
stehen rund 100 davon vor jahren wurden
sie ausgemustert von der bundeswehr die
ukraine hätte sie gern wird aber von der
bundesregierung hingehalten der antrag
zum export wurde anfang märz gestellt
bisher ist ja nicht bewilligt
der für die bewilligung einer
exportgenehmigung von waffen brauchen
sie einen beschluss des bundes
sicherheitskabinetts der wird einstimmig
getroffen und es bisher nicht getroffen
worden
offenbar blockieren scholz und die spd
warum ist bis heute nicht klar im mai
war scholz im verteidigungsausschuss die
sitzung war nicht öffentlich dass
vertrauliche protokolle liegt im zdf vor
scholz erklärte bei waffenlieferungen
gebe es keinen absoluten grundsatz und
einen solchen werde er auch nicht
öffentlich benennen dies gelte auch für
schwere waffen
ausgeschlossen sind wir stolz nur
moderne westliche kampfpanzer
dazu zählen die halten leopard 1 aber
sicher nicht
das ist ein skandal dass schützenpanzer
und auch schwerere panzer in deutschland
stehen die der ukraine helfen könnten
das kostet jeden tag menschen leben das
auch eine verantwortung die dieser
bundeskanzler trägt in einer woche wird
scholz gastgeber sein eines
hochsicherheitsgefängnisses
um den schutz der ukraine gehen und um
eine so einfache wie offene frage kann
ausgerechnet das zögerliche deutschland
den westen beisammen halten um putin zu
trotzen
[Musik]